foreign
[Music]
what did you want before Miami
I just wanted to escape my life
[Music]
do you like bartending it's not really
what I do
jewelry
you came along and gave me these
unexpected
magical moment
that made me remember who I really was
[Music]
why are you in London I'm gonna put on a
show at this famous theater
disconnected we can wake them up with a
wave of passion they've never felt
before hell yeah without further Ado I
give you the Visionary artist magic mine
money
the real question is why does she feel
like she has to choose it sounds to me
she just needs to let go
[Music]
some good
maybe that as well
[Music]
you're not shutting me down not this
time you're so good at this I'm not
gonna just let us give up on it I want
every woman that walks into this theater
to feel that a woman can have whatever
she wants whatever she wants
[Music]
wait I know you you were a cop right did
you arrest her what's your name Kim
lets you up for the warning right
foreign
court order for asset seizures so
they're taking my car you and radio
silent on me is that what this is about
my feelings for you were so intense that
I got scared is that true no that's my
cousin Gary I swear to God he's my
cousin he's my second cousin there's
something seriously wrong with you I'm
an Uber driver and I don't have a car
I'm gonna lose my house
look at this need a car date our son
this summer and bring him out of his
shell before College in exchange we'll
give you a Buick Regal date is in quotes
husband the code breaker
you've just been so worried about our
son he's going to Princeton in the fall
no I've heard of it and we tried
everything to bring him out of his shell
he doesn't come out of his room he
doesn't talk to girls and drinks so when
you say date him do you mean date him or
date him yes date him date him hard I'll
date his brains out he volunteers at the
animal shelter
hi mind if I touch your wiener what your
dog
how about I give you a ride home
um this isn't the way to my house the
shortcut you're my hostage what you got
down there something for me
why you tried kidnapping me you're 19.
grow up
this kid is Undateable have a drink
together he'll have a Long Island Iced
Tea
this is the worst iced tea I've ever had
okay
I don't know what to do I just know my
mom would have wanted me to save the
house I'm probably just nervous aren't
you loosen them up you can go skinny
dipping what about sharks none here
jellyfish not the season it's really the
lack of life partner right now okay
he's actually really sweet
part about getting older is not having
to care about people think I'm an adult
now I can make my own decisions that's
good you want to save her favorite
come on you're getting out of here you
don't belong here touch me get
together
[Music]
Maddie you can't outrun the cops I can't
lose my license
I was just wondering if you wanted to um
you know go out sometime you want to get
a coffee now yes now
I'll just hang on when I wake up well I
know I'm gonna be her name is Sadie
I mean I know this sounds crazy I think
she might be the one
who goes along with you she really is
great you'll see
any word she goes to them I bet she
hasn't even seen your text she does
travel a lot for work go to her I'm
going to London
[Music]
get it it's a grand romantic gesture
amazing 5 000 miles as far as a girl
you've only met once especially if she's
the one who ghosted yeah
no no she didn't ghost me she just
doesn't have an international calling
plan oh right
[Music]
where am I oh God you have the wrong guy
I'm a former wait wait
can you walk goal
so confused they kept asking me about
the tax man they asked about the attacks
man didn't think I am attachment
enjoy the tax man oh my God oh my God
you got me kidnapped and tortured all
after one day
I saw the rock you're the one who flew
to London
it was a romantic gesture
Victory bumpy Hunter on the continent I
want her life
bigger than you and me
it never occur to you that he could be a
foreign asset trying to compromise your
mission
who the hell are you
I'm the boyfriend
[Music]
do you trust me is that a joke
hey hi you a fighter I'm just a regular
girl who hates it when bad guys win then
you're really gonna hate me
[Music]
we were a perfect team I was riding the
high
we all know that doesn't last
okay I caught my sister and my boyfriend
of three years having sex in our
apartment
how are you you have a place to stay
I may know a guy just um be careful
[Music]
complicated
I saw you lose
and I'm the only one who can make sure
that doesn't happen again
your new guy
I'm training him to break you
[Music]
She's Mine always will be right
full of lovers
I'm addicted to you
others
sometimes
it's hard to tell the difference
[Music]
hi Barbies
hi Ken
hey Barbie hi Barbie hi Barbie hi Barbie
hi Barbie hi Barbie
hi Ken
I can now
[Music]
I thought I might stay over tonight why
because we're girlfriend boyfriends you
do what
I'm actually not sure
[Music]
it's okay ladies let's do this
[Applause]
[Music]
I'm coming with you
did you bring your rollerblades
I literally go nowhere without them
ah looks like this beach is a little too
much Beach for you Ken if I wasn't
severely injured I would beat you off
right now Ken I'll beat you up with you
any day Ken anyone who wants to beat him
up has to beat me off first I will beat
both of you off at the same time
nobody's gonna beat anyone off
[Music]
off
Ally
Sean oh my God what are you doing here
you know why I'm just visiting my old
haunts on the off chance I might run
into an X from 10 years ago how many of
you running two so far
again
let's go think about what would happen
if you hadn't left all those years ago
I've been kind of wondering the same
thing recently like if maybe I made the
wrong decision
I haven't felt that free in
I don't even know how long Sean honey
Mom hey I
what a wonderful thing for us all to be
here so thank you to the bride and groom
for giving us a reason to celebrate to
Sean and Cassidy
I need to see this through whatever it
is you mean like with you in the groom
you can just call him Sean
hi you're still here if my being here is
making you uncomfortable no no it
wouldn't be very cool of me to kick out
one of Sean's oldest friends
[Music]
[Applause]
oh she was cool she actually reminds me
a lot of me at that age
working like a nudist I was I have an
idea
keep your eyes on the iPad Bradley pit
Campbell do not taste the naked ladies
this has gone way too far I don't know I
don't know what to do anymore
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
you broke the rules he went to the above
World a man was drowning I had to save
him this obsession with humans has to
stop I just want to know more about them
[Music]
I can help
in that world unless you become a human
yourself is that even possible
that's what I live for
[Music]
something about you seems different I
can't quite figure it out she got legs
you idiot
's
[Music]
he's a human you're a mermaid that
doesn't make us enemies
foreign
[Music]
fly off to Alaska okay I'll call you
when I land
hello Mrs Lerner your husband was on a
helicopter that went down in the Pacific
Jesse at first it was so hard to let go
I refused to admit
but then I started to think that the
good days could be good weeks or good
months I'm finally ready to live again
Emma Sam
I guess you all know that I've been
madly in love with Emma for a few years
now the family family
hello sweetheart it's Jesse I'm alive
I can't wear that to reunite with your
long-lost husband
made it back to you I tell you how sorry
I was with you I'm engaged
you and Jesse had this beautiful life
together and then we all thought he was
dead and you found love again with a
great guy no matter what you do you're
gonna break somebody's heart
[Music]
incredibly verbose but accurate
I just want her to love me more than she
loves her that was wildly inappropriate
I'm gonna stop no man for God's sakes
just keep talking
him or
or she should be with the person that
she loves the most not in a person that
loves her the most I can't lose him so
don't go tell him
are we really not going to talk about
your husband in law I what
[Music]
what kind of story were you thinking
about how something to prison oh all
right and uh what about a prison
interests you jail
for sure
happy anniversary we're so lucky yeah so
Elliot tells me you're a writer and
you're the last one it should have done
better there's lots of new voices
refugees cancer murder abuse I'm an old
voice you're the best voice maybe if Dad
hadn't just been verbally abusive it
would have been a bestseller don't say
that
your Memoir is great your new book is
great how are you feeling a little off
my game the only reason she makes me a
salad is because she wants me to lose
weight which is passive aggressive I
want you to be healthy it doesn't matter
can you shut up and keep talking Don you
want to intervene here we can do this at
home Milani looks tired
imagine what are you nuts you get BOTOX
well I just get a little bit right here
you know I can still move my eyebrows
watch watch
so expressive
oh look come on we'll go sneak up on him
can you say anything no I can't it feels
too late oh my God oh my gosh
right here
no I don't think I can I can't
if I did say that you took it out of
context are you gonna fight me now
he's been lying to me this whole time I
wasn't lying I was encouraging that's
not true you were lying to be
encouraging you know what as an actor
Mark isn't always great so the times
where you don't think he's good what do
you send them you're so fantastic really
Mom you're always expecting the best
from me you're welcome
[Music]
I needed to do something meaningful what
you do is is kind of meaningful it's a
who no one
this whole world is falling apart and
this is what's consuming you well you're
not helping
I love you
oh okay well never mind
[Music]
the leaf to blot her tears it would be
weird to give her tissue Mira we made
children's books maybe it's better to
prepare them life will inevitably Crush
their hopes and dreams
[Music]
you know I'm just wearing my dead
boyfriend's shirt and texting his whole
number
Rob wanted to make sure you got one of
these I have a phone you have a personal
phone this is a work phone
making me inside of me
do you have a question for me yes Mr do
you really believe in all these things
you sing you obviously know nothing
about it what
[Music]
it's been two years since you passed and
I still can't believe it who is sending
me these texts every morning I open my
eyes hoping I'll still see you I must
have the dead boyfriend's number that's
super sad I think they're nice there's
nothing wrong putting yourself back out
there again you're going there get the D
you make it sound like I have a vitamin
deficiency yeah you kind of do you have
a vitamin D deficiency because when the
sun comes up maybe we just take it a
little slower go
I think I might have feelings for
someone I've never met please fix your
receiving are saying something it might
be crazy but love doesn't always follow
the rules
[Music]
I'm wearing it to the Opera tonight I'm
gonna go see her these are from a
literal stranger I just need to put a
face to these texts
[Music]
don't know you I'm not sure
oh my God you just get yourself a date
the normal way
she thinks I am interesting you need to
tell her the truth you should have said
something to her right away
I was looking forward to this I just
felt like I knew you or something
do you think you could fall in love with
someone just through their words
I think you're very cute
the more I get to know her the better I
like her
oh
looks like this don't just happen love
is a plan for each and every one of us
hi this is Celine Dion sure and I'm
Mariah Carey love comes to those who
believe it and this is really me oh my
gosh hi
[Music]
everything all right in there trying to
have a private moment my bad
not that private then
how you doing yeah good yeah yeah
cool cool
it's dumb right let me ask that's me
I'm gonna meet my ex for the first time
since the breakup and you're still
calling it The Breakup we're fine we
were better than five we moved in
together but we had Hamilton tickets
this is a serious commitment
so what happened she cheated on me with
my best friend
with him well it hurts a little bit I
mean I got it the arms are nice but why
don't you even talk about are you just
gonna sit there and say that to me well
she said my arms in there
I went through the same sort of thing
not too long ago she was his life coach
apparently she opened his mind I mean
her legs all of her underwear looks like
this seriously you'd have to sew like 15
of these together to get the pants I'm
wearing right now the worst part I left
my favorite record at his place let's go
find a record shop right now and I'll
buy you a new coffee but I don't want
any coffee I want my copy you must have
changed the locks back I'm gonna break
in someone must have a keeper juices go
I'll keep them chatting you look for the
key room for one more
what the hell do you think you're doing
no I wasn't
um
I just caught this boy going through
your naked drawer what have you done
[Music]
sometimes you just gotta see what
happens just go where the breeze takes
you
back are you sure you're down for this
yeah
by the way your man swiped me on Tinder
like a week ago
[Music]
give me your phone or anybody now
there's a word in Korean
Indian
it means providence
or fate
do you believe in that that's just
something Koreans say to seduce someone
[Music]
what a good story this is
childhood sweethearts who reconnect 20
years later and realized they were meant
for each other and the story I would be
the evil white American husbands
standing in the way of Destiny shut up
there's just this kid in my head for
such a long time I think I just missed
him did he miss you
hey song
[Music]
I'm really sure how to feel about it
and the way you move
[Music]
makes me feel like
the guy flew 13 hours to be here I'm not
gonna tell you that you can't see him or
something
if I find Google
[Music]
if two strangers walk by each other in
the street and their clothes
accidentally brushed
that means there have been 8 000 layers
between them I want you to stay
[Music]
I want you to stay
honey maybe we should just call it a
night you go ahead I gotta finish these
centerpieces and rearrange the seating
chart
yes
hello Mom now is not the time I just
want to ask is that genetics or is it
like Pilates
we got your gift it's your Something
Borrowed brings you good luck except for
Uncle Greg who ended up decapitated on
that forklift but that's not the knives
fall
someone just left that in the bathroom
you forgot to put his shirt all the way
up
is it time for dinner
you look so much better than the rest of
us I think the left boot is slightly
lower than the right food something
doesn't feel right
foreign
[Applause]
here's the plan
spray him in the ice
it won't work why so many steps
not once did I wonder
if I'd be walking handcuffed Through the
Jungle with a life grenade
oh you got it I got it you got it okay
[Music]
I just scrolling on me I wanted
something less traditional
nobody with my family
[Music]
Hallelujah
stunning our sisters
Carol thank you for the cake knife
I freaking love this cake knife
[Music]
got a man
you are good dear Carmen and you will
live eternally in Bliss when will that
happen when you die of course
I have been my brother's housekeeper
from when I was 16. if I cannot say a
directory where will I go God does not
abandon his children dear blessed Jesus
help me
father my husband every night you come
home drunk make him the same food for
breakfast lunch and dinner until he
doesn't come back
I will pay you back I promise
forgive me Father I took some money from
my brother's piggy bank you must put the
money back
[Music]
hello may I help you I have some things
you might like to buy how did you
require these what's your name Caroline
my name is Pablo
[Music]
why don't you have anyone
it is red and beautiful cheers
[Music]
guys we are here with the stars of super
Society Adam Clark and his girlfriend
you are heading down to Mexico to wrap
up the trilogy we're hosting Hollywood
royalty for the next few weeks so you
want me to babysit these Hollywood logos
Mr Clark he's probably doing his silent
meditation
hey
um I'm in character so this doesn't
count right
the best thing you can do for you right
now is to say absolutely nothing about
the breakup every time I'm a dialect
Adam Clark breaks up with a girl like
Sophie Wilder you are the one that gets
the short end of the stick it's you I'm
not
I don't know if it's short or not I
didn't look at the nudes when they
leaked I just made them go away
I'm sad I heard an audiobook that said
you're supposed to lean into that like
let yourself be sad
sorry about the towels
have a great stay oh my God he walked in
on you completely naked good evening
Miss Wilder late night call me Sophie
you have seen me naked I wasn't looking
well now I'm offended night
hi Miss Wilder I was wondering can I
take a tour I'd actually like to go
dancing I'd be happy to assist you with
that what time
at midnight
[Music]
she's leaving soon this can't go
anywhere the idea of us getting back
together it's got legs he cheated on you
this guy's a monster it was a five-year
relationship kind of complicated isn't
it laughs
[Music]
I wish we could go somewhere we didn't
have to hide
doing where is she what the hell is
going on this was a huge mistake because
I'm not on vacation I'm supposed to be
here for work
I'm just giveness
[Music]
I mean cheating it's it's actually very
hip it's very French you know why do you
think we all go to can every year for
the movies
[Applause]
Miss Chen what are you doing here look
I'm still pending at Harvard and I was
just wondering if you had heard anything
oh it's Harvard hello you want to give
her a full ride I'll let her know right
away it's funny
do you ever feel like we have wasted our
youth sitting on the sidelines what do
you want us to be doing like games and
parties and dances
will you go to prom with me yes yes do
you accept the terms and conditions of
my proposal it would be my honor
it's pole dancing wow you really know
how to make a boy feel special Harvard
is my life's ambition help me figure out
how to get in you need a killer letter
of rest your team captain
I can't believe I'm about to say this
what about Graham Lincoln's death the
Harvard Alum senator So the plan is we
stage a run-in with the most popular guy
in school at a party that we were not
invited to and then ask him for a
gigantic favorite easy peasy you okay
Ben yeah
I regret everything
he's a neanderthal who's only forms of
communication are Grunts and go Bulldogs
I'm sorry I'd be happy to tutor you you
know as an apology
here it is oh
you're five minutes late are you really
willing to compromise your values for a
letter of wreck heads up
just a dumb joke before this did you
know who I was before this why'd you
offer to tutor me
[Music]
people come to me their expectations of
who I am or who I should be
it's my life and I am not gonna let it
Pass Me By
[Music]
Graham Lansing is not who I thought he
was you are playing to Harvard
we'll look back on high school you think
your biggest regret will be it's nothing
that beats Harvard
is there I'm sorry I didn't catch the
name of the school is it hergard's
[Music]
Graham Lansing
Graham Lansing oh stop why do you guys
know who that is
[Music]
I remember growing up
let's convince I traveled the world just
made these mind-blowing people connect
Jesus you're like 11 19 in like three
weeks are you jaded yet
hey jaded shut up
[Music]
you're like my sister is that it yeah no
but we're more like really good friends
yeah but he's tight nights are good boys
I know she can be like a mess but I
don't really have any other friends I'm
gonna play off the dramatic Diner is
this actually a dance costume sporting
some serious cleavage
he won
what's going on that's am I going away
dinner when are you falling to our South
America come on
[Music]
you probably just want to get to bed he
doesn't ever drive
can I come
[Music]
walking to your door
come to me I'll meet someone
[Music]
it's a beautiful boy
what are the odds we'll both be arriving
right now
I'm a bitter old man and he's like shut
up
[Music]
you're happy because for me life
first
to this one feeling
[Music]
I wanted the summer to be remembered
next Friday I'll be three years since
they told me that they didn't think I'd
make it more than three years that's it
then we're celebrating that
[Music]
they've not seen the worst of it like us
though have they
what are you studying in this
ridiculously happy book it's interesting
when something is burned it's particles
are released into the atmosphere to last
on forever
[Music]
we're gonna build the biggest fire that
we possibly can and we'll burn the items
that we collect like Vikings and in
doing so I'll live on
if I'm a normal person
foreign
[Music]